(air whooshes)
(clicking)
- All these platforms
become all kinds of content.
You know what Instagram started off as?
Photography nerds.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, true, yeah.
- Taking fucking sunsets
with a fucking filter.
Facebook was college talk, hooking up.
You know, Twitter was tech nerds.
They all start as something.
- True.
- And they all evolve to everything.
(shouting)
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(shutter clicks)
(piano music)
Good morning, on this beautiful Tuesday
in March, last day of March.
March 31st.
It has been an interesting
month for so many of us.
This is tea with Gary Vee.
I am your host Gary Vaynerchuk.
I am humbled.
This has been an incredible series.
Two hours of Q and A.
We're going deep, we're
going deep as fuck.
Let's get into the first question Dustin.
- [Dustin] First up will be Rashad.
- Really excited about this episode.
- Good morning.
- Good morning Rashad, how are you?
- Good, good,
How are you Gary?
Thanks for having me.
- Yeah, of course.
Where are you from?
- From Austin right now.
And very, very excited to be here.
- Thank you, what can I answer for you?
- Yeah, let me give you a little
quick background about myself.
It's been a journey.
So I was born and raised in Iran and
I graduated from high school
in West Chester, Pennsylvania.
Went back for college, back to Iran.
Got my associate degree in
Architecture over there.
And then, long story short right now,
I'm a real estate agent here in Austin.
And I guess the question
that I have for you,
is more of a mindset kind of question.
So, there has been
multiple times in my life
that I've reached my short time goals.
And after that I start
feeling like accomplished
and feeling good about
myself and then I stop.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
So, how do you manage to
don't stop, keep going,
and just grinding.
- Make a Macro goal.
(stuttering)
Yeah, I mean for me I
want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time,
and that comes in the form,
in my opinion, of not only
building successful businesses,
but giving back to the most people
in the entrepreneurial game and
I want to buy the New
York Jets professionally
and those are my
professional kind of goals.
Outside of who I am as a human.
And so, I think you need
to make bigger goals.
Because, I'm with you.
There's a huge letdown.
I made a video already that says
today's the worst day of my life.
And it's the video I'm going to play,
when I buy the New York Jets.
There's a letdown if you love the process.
And I think you love the process.
And I think when you achieve that goal,
there's always an inherent letdown.
When I go on vacation,
I look forward to it
for so long that when
I get there on day one,
I'm actually more upset.
Because it was more fun the weeks before,
getting pumped for it
than the actual event.
- Right.
- Right?
So, you and I may share that DNA.
I think you need to make
much bigger fucking goals.
- To be honest with you,
whatever I have in my mind,
I just know that I'm going to achieve it.
I know I'm going to be there.
Because I work very hard.
- Go big, big, big.
Make yourself uncomfortable.
You might be making
yourself too comfortable.
You might like the idea of achieving goals
more than actually achieving goals.
Do you see where I'm going?
You may like little goals,
that are achievable.
You might be subconsciously
trying to portray
that you can make shit happen,
by keeping shit small.
You might have so much more in you.
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah.
- And, by the way, one of the reasons
you may be upset is
that you might actually
realize that you're making small goals.
It may look good to everybody else,
but you somehow deeps inside,
know that you have so much more in you.
You need to make bigger fucking goals bro.
- I see where you're going,
I see where you're going.
(stuttering)
Because I've been listening to you,
and I like the idea of going slow
and actually trying to build it.
So, when I first started
for the first month,
nothing happened.
Right now, before this
whole COVID-19 happened,
I ended up closing.
I'm just doing leasing right now.
I don't do bigger deals
because I'm just starting.
- You're starting.
- Yeah, I was leasing like
three to four homes every week.
And I've been to this
town for not even a year.
- I love it.
- And it's just like, you know.
And I'm feeling like.
(sighing)
- Bigger goals bro, your goal,
We're talking real estate now, homes.
- Yeah.
- Your goal should be the number one
real estate agent in New York city.
- Not even in Austin.
- Fuck Austin, Austin's small.
It's a beautiful, by the way
I love Austin, it's epic,
and by the way, that's exactly right,
notice the difference
between where we're at,
like, you're like, "Hey,
I'm going to be like"
"a top player in Austin."
And I'm like, "That's
cool but like what about"
"being the number one
agent in New York City."
- Right.
- Now all of a sudden,
you've got a big goal,
now all of a sudden right now,
you're just fucking renting in Austin.
You're seven years, you're 12 years away
from being number one in New York.
That's what makes a fun,
slow, big, you know.
You're not going to achieve it tomorrow
and then be sad the
next day, kind of goal.
You need a framework play.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(laughing)
You see it?
- Thank you.
Yeah, I do.
- I know, I can see you see it.
You've got it brother, take care.
- Cheers bro.
- We're off to a good fucking,
cheers bro.
We're off to a good fucking start here on
Tea with Gary Vee, I'm fired up with that.
That was real some advice.
Something's that's probably
going to help a ton of you this morning.
I appreciate Maria,
Genaveve, Rock Dance Theater,
Dr. Clinton Bayne, the chiropractor,
you're getting a follow,
I'm your 85th follower Clinton Bayne.
That's what happens when you
share this show on Twitter.
Casey Langely, boom,
a little like for you,
a little follow.
I'm your 678th, and I'm
retweeting you Casey,
so you're going to get some new love.
Tea Time, Tea Time.
Devon Alexander always here with us.
Doctor Tachreen, always here with us.
Abi Galvez, you get a little like,
you get a follow, I'm
your 75th follower there.
And Tom is in the building,
with a beanie nonetheless.
I love it.
(chuckling)
- How you doing Tom?
- I'm doing okay, how are you doing Gary?
- Really well actually.
- Good, I want to shout
out your team Gary Vee,
and Dustin, man they do
an awesome job, thank you.
- Thank you for that, I agree.
- They are fantastic.
So, good to talk to you.
Background, I've got 22 years
background in live theater,
guerrilla theater, independent theater.
As an actor and director.
Ran one company for 13 years,
ran a mixed use art venue for three years.
I got nine novels
published with Random House
and Simon & Schuster.
- Wow.
- That was cool.
- Yeah, I got to write
for the comic book Spawn
a few years ago, for a few issues.
- Wow!
- That was really cool.
- Wow.
- Oh, wait for it, wait for it.
And then I've got to
write some scripts for
app video games, like phone
games, and stuff like that.
Really cool.
Just finished shooting my first
short film a couple of months ago,
that was a good time, had a great time.
One of the problems that I'm having,
I've read your books, watched your videos.
All this stuff and everything resonates
really deeply with me and I'm trying to
tell all my writer friends,
"You got to watch Gary Vee,"
"it's going to totally change everything."
The issue I'm having though is translating
everything I hear you teaching,
everything you're doing on Tea Time,
to a strictly entertainment
based business.
Because the margins are slim as fuck.
You know?
I'm sure you've probably
encountered this too,
with your writing.
Like people hear Random House or Spawn,
you can just walk in and
get a job with whoever.
Like no, it doesn't work that way dude.
It does not work that way.
I need like a thousand followers
to pay me like two bucks
a month and I'm good.
That's it, that's all I need.
- Is that how you're thinking?
- Yeah, that's really it.
- Well I got good news.
We're going to go right into this.
Literally during the
first 45 seconds of this,
I'm like, "Fuck, should I hire this guy?"
You're clearly wildly creative.
Where do you live?
- Phoenix.
- Phoenix, so.
Let's play it out.
- Okay.
- Just kind of, I'm not the biggest fan
of subscription or
content base businesses,
but I'm a huge fan of access.
So when I actually hear
that a thousand people
paying you two bucks a month, right?
Because you're like dude
I need $2,000 a month.
Is that what you said?
- Yeah.
- Dude, writing for spawn,
having books published.
What kind of books were they?
They were traditionally published
were young adult and horror basically.
Dude, you're a, couple of
things run through my mind.
I'm pretty pumped right now,
I think I'm going to change
your life right on the spot.
I'm not even kidding.
- Do it.
- Couple of things.
One, that level of ability to write in a
world so many people want to be writers,
I think you should create a business where
once a week you send
a detailed curriculum,
you clearly an write that out.
And, two times a month,
there's Tea with Tom,
or there's a two hour closed live stream.
A zoom, a closed zoom.
Where, whatever holds a 1,000 people,
I don't know if zoom holds a 1,000,
but I think that you can easily,
just on what I just heard,
easily create a five
dollar a month business,
you charge people five dollars
a month for a weekly email,
and a bi-weekly live,
closed, two hour session.
Pure Q and A, with the pure
agenda of helping people
become better writers.
- Yeah, okay so.
- Number two, number two.
Immediately starting yesterday,
I want you to go to your best
illustrator design friend,
which you clearly have
made through these years.
- Yeah.
- And I want you to create your Star Wars.
Now, let me explain what I mean by that.
I want you to go to the well in your head.
And I want you to create
three to four characters
in a make believe land.
And I want you to create
an Instagram account
around this land.
What I want ultimately, is for you to sell
$35 to $70 dollar hoodies
with these characters on them,
but God forbid it takes off
miraculously on Instagram
or TikTok, it could lead to somebody,
you know this, IP is where
the money is in what you do.
- Yeah, for sure.
- You need to take the
leap and actually create
the get-a-long gang.
Create, you know, Star Wars is the apex.
You create, when I hear
how awesome you are.
Where your ambitions
financially are so low,
because you love what you do so much.
I'm like fuck, this is a layup.
This guy's probably, what's your,
I'm going to pre-sell $5 dollars
a month for you right now.
Literally right now.
What is your email?
- Tom@Tomleveen.com
- Great, even better.
No, it's okay, it's okay.
I just wanted to,
because you're probably about
to get 40 to 500 emails.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- So, Tom.
Dustin, can people see
Tom Leveen name in bottom
left hand corner like I can see it?
- [Dustin] Yeah, they can see it.
And I'm also looking on
LinkedIn and the feedback
looks really positive there.
- You mean the comments?
- [Dustin] Yeah, like they are really
into Tom and everything.
- Yeah, because Tom is very
sweet and has good vibes.
Tom, clearly, let me just
say this very quickly.
Listen, I've been doing this a long time,
I don't do this often.
Tom's got too many W's
on his board, you know?
You just don't get to
write for fucking Spawn.
You just don't get to.
You don't get to write nine books
that are published by real publishers.
Even if they didn't sell for shit.
And I mean that Tom.
Like, obviously they did
sell, maybe they didn't.
But it really is completely irrelevant.
Like, getting to that point, you know.
It's very clear to me, that
you're a creative fellow,
and I really do believe
that there's a ton of people
that can benefit from a
well thought out email.
Or plans, ideas.
Tom, basically actually let
me ask a couple of questions.
- Yeah.
- Do you think that you
can send 52 emails a year,
that you have 52, thought's
ideas, strategies, inspirations,
and if was something you really focus on.
Do you think that you could help
people become better writers?
- Yeah, I do that already.
Not to that.
Yes, yes.
- And you like the idea
of spending two hours
every week on live with
a thousand people on.
- Yes.
- Good.
- Okay, can I?
- You can do anything.
- Okay, so.
I totally agree.
I did it a little before.
Maybe a little bit is the problem.
I've tried something similar
to that and it didn't work.
So, now how.
- Let's talk.
- What am I doing?
- What did you do?
- So last year
- Well first of all, I probably just gave
you 100 customers.
(stuttering)
You're probably going to have
100 customers by the
time I hang up with you.
- Thank you.
- So that might just be,
you might have just needed a
little bit of a starting point.
- Yeah.
- So let me listen to make
sure you don't fuck it up.
Go ahead.
- So, listening over the
last few years like I did.
I was doing a weekly, first
it was a Facebook live,
then a YouTube live.
Where it was just talking
to different people,
doing some writing stuff like that.
Some coaching and whatever else.
I really enjoy teaching
writing, it's a lot of fun.
- Great.
- And one of the things that regardless
of whatever the class is about,
that I always tell people,
is as soon as you decide
someone should pay you
for writing fiction,
you just started a small business.
And nobody is telling writers that.
Nobody is telling about it at all.
It pisses me off.
- Good.
- So, I've already kind
of been doing that,
but we're talking six,
seven, 10, 15 viewers
tuning into that.
So clearly, I'm doing something wrong,
I assume I'm doing something wrong.
To get that sort of viewership
up into the first place.
- You might be a great writer,
and a great creative, and a great teacher,
and you just might not
be a great marketer.
And that's okay.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Like, to me, when you
were done with that live,
did you post-produce it and
take all of the questions
and thoughts and make 83 or nine or 14
pieces of content and
put that onto Instagram,
things of that nature.
Have you taken a hundred
dollars and learned
how to run ads on Facebook and Instagram.
- Not well, no.
- Right.
Have you run pre-roll YouTube,
where you pop up and say hey.
- No, no.
- Yeah, there's so many like,
again, in the same way that if,
I mean if God forbid I was creative enough
to create spawn or like McFarlane or
to be able to write.
I probably have Hunger
games, I probably have spawn
on my resume already, because I've made
myself a superhero, let alone,
and I'm a fucking business man.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I know that part.
So, couple of things.
It's irrelevant because
I'm telling you right now,
Tom@tomleveen.com
Like, you're about to have
400 emails in your inbox.
Actually, I need you
to tweet me in an hour,
and tell me how many
people have hit you up.
So it's Tom@tomleveen.com
I think your business is
$5 bucks a month, not two.
It's $5 bucks a month.
Which is fucking nothing.
- It's nothing.
- Nothing.
It's 60 dollars a year.
The amount of people
that want to be writers
that are watching right now
that pay $60 bucks for two books
that bring them no value a year,
- Yeah!
- Is a ton.
Do you know what platform
you're going to use
to charge $5 a month, and
like how to put it behind
a closed live stream and
things of that nature?
If you don't, and I can see
you're grinding your mind.
If somebody knows what
platform Tom should use
to create a closed community that charges,
I haven't monetized my audience,
but I'm sure there's
a ton of smart things.
Whether it's Squarespace,
whether WordPress.
- Yeah.
- Something else that I don't know.
So please hit up Tom, in the title if you
hit up Tom with that,
say Tom I know how to help you monetize.
Tom, literally 15 people
from my community right now
are going to email you
at Tom@tomleveen.com
They are going to tell
you what platform to use.
You're going to set that up today.
You're going to put
your bank account there.
You're going to name Tom's writing course,
whatever you decide.
You're then going to email back all
100 to 500 people that just emailed.
At Tom@tomleveen.com
And you're going to say,
"Yo, I'm so flattered."
Probably, you should
probably reply to them first.
As soon as you hang up.
Be like, "I'm so flattered,"
"I'll get back to you in 24 hours."
You set it up, you send them the email.
And 80% of the people the email you,
because some people back out,
between their hype right now and tomorrow.
80% of those people are going to sign up,
and you're going to have a base.
And then you're going
to take this recording,
once I put it onto YouTube,
learn how to splice it out.
And then take this and then
start posting this video,
because this is your sales pitch.
And now you froze for me.
And I love how you froze,
you're like looking up into the air.
Dustin did he freeze for you too?
- [Dustin] Yeah, there he goes.
- All right, Tom you're back.
- I'm back.
- That's it bro.
- That's it?
- $5 a month, $5 a
month, once a week email.
Very detailed.
I recommend maybe giving them five links.
Like I want you to put
work in for their $5.
- Oh, sure.
- I want you to find
maybe one to three links
every week on the internet of
things they should watch or read.
Right?
I want you to write, you know,
I can see that you got it in you.
So, you write today's learning
is about character creation.
Today's learning is about writers block.
Today's, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then, maybe on your third livestream
that you do for two hours every two weeks.
On the third one, which
is a month and a half in.
Maybe you bring in somebody
who is a real friend of yours,
who is highly accomplished
or like somebody you admire.
I think, when I hear $5 a month,
from somebody that's got it like that.
I see a real business.
- Okaydoke.
- Do you have access to
your email right now?
- I do.
- Can you tell me real quick
how many emails you got?
- Yeah, sure.
Something that might be
helpful for other people
listening to as long
as we're doing that is,
dealing with, I don't like the
term imposter syndrome personally,
but that's a shorthand
that everybody understands.
Because again, everyone's like,
"You did this, you did that."
Like, yeah but I still
think that I suck though.
What do we do with that?
You know what I'm saying?
- We go to therapy so that we can shit on
our Mom and Dad who
put that into our head,
and then move on with our lives.
- Fair enough.
- That's insecurity.
- That is insecurity.
- And that's somebody DNA or parenting,
how are we doing Tom?
- I'm at 24 so far.
- Very nice, good little start.
(laughing)
You know, that's insecurity.
- Yeah.
- That was put inside of you.
The results are too obvious.
Your kind energy is too obvious.
You need to fucking cut that
cancer out of your body.
That's bullshit.
You're clearly not an imposter.
You clearly got it.
24 people are interested in you right now,
or interested in helping you.
A lot of them are captivated
by this video right now.
And as I transition to the next person,
they're going to email you and so.
As I transition here,
I'm going to literally
tweet out your email.
To help everybody make it faster.
I wish you well, you got this.
This is layup city.
- Thanks Gary, I appreciate you man.
- I appreciate you back brother.
Have a great day.
All right.
Give me one second Dustin.
Dustin, what was his last name
even though I pronounced it.
- [Dustin] Veen.
- Veen?
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- Leveen?
- [Dustin] Yeah, correct.
Yeah people are really into Tom.
Both on Facebook and Instagram.
- Bro, I'll be honest with you.
I might sign up for it.
Right?
Because like, I might want Ragav to do it.
Like, you know how much we're
into character creation.
Like, I think so many people
can invent a little character
that they have been
doodling their whole life,
learn how to write a little
bit of an origin story.
Post like crazy on Instagram.
And then like, literally you know
weirdly build up a following.
And then minimally have a $25,000 a
year merchandise business.
Hoodie, hat, t-shirt.
I don't think people get it.
And then God forbid somebody
from Hollywood sees it,
and fucking turns it into
a Netflix animated show.
Like, people don't get it man.
Life is amazing when you take
it by the fucking throat.
Hello!
- Hey Gary!
Whoa, wait a minute.
Hold on.
- [Dustin] One second.
- Okay, no worries.
Who are we doing?
Is it Jodie?
- [Dustin] Jodie.
- Okay, good.
I didn't think that was your voice, Jodie.
How are you?
(laughing)
- I'm good, how are you Mr. Vee?
- I am super well.
- So, I have a wildly
specific question about
a dilemma that I'm currently
facing in my business.
Bit of background.
So, I'm a fashion designer
and I've been actively
developing my luxury street wear label,
for about three and a half years before
becoming an official LLC in January.
- Knarli.
- It's called Knarli.
- Love it.
- And I design unisex,
reversible knitwear produced
in a highly sustainable manner
that is virtually zero waste,
using 3D knit technology.
I plan to launch for
public sale next month
but Corona virus literally
chased my production
from China to Italy,
and now LA and Brooklyn.
Actually this halt is really good,
because it's kind of forced me to
stop and think twice about production.
I'm at a point where I
need to decide whether
to continue with my original
plan of starting with
flat knitwear, make
money, and then transition
into 3D knitwear, or
skip the flat knitting,
and jump right into 3D knit wear.
Because flat knitting
production has ended up being
a lot more expensive that I anticipated.
And it's only about 20 to
35% less than 3D knitting.
- I'm following.
So, isn't 3D knitting a big
part of the Knarli brand story?
Because it's like the first thing
that came out of your mouth.
- Yeah.
- Well that's your fucking answer.
- Okay.
- People make financial
decisions all the time,
that compromise the story.
- Okay.
Yeah, that makes sense, because when I was
first going in there,
it was a lot more easier and accessible
to do the flat knitting first.
- People pick ease, people pick faster,
people pick more money over the story.
- Right.
Right.
Okay, cool.
- The story.
- Yeah.
- Knarli with a k, story is the 3D part.
- Right.
- You were compromising
it for convenience.
- Right.
(stuttering)
- Also, a lot of, I was reaching out
to 3D manufactures and on-demand
manufacturing for awhile,
and because I'm a small
start-up and I look young,
there's a lot of rejection.
- Cynicism.
Yeah.
- Yeah, sure, and I get it.
- Let me ask you a question.
How many?
- How many what?
- How many did you reach out to?
- Four, but there's only like
four that are within my reach.
In America.
- Understandable, I respect that.
- Yeah.
3D knitting, it's like super small.
- Super small.
- There's only one manufacturer
technically of that machine.
- Yes.
- So, okay.
Thank you.
- Are you going to be able
to get them to do it, though?
- Yeah.
I mean, yes.
Yeah.
Because after I actually
had someone reach out to me
back again that rejected me last year,
and now as they saw kind
of the traction it's
getting with my branding,
they are kind of more interested.
And so, I have a feeling that
if I really, really push it,
I can get it to happen.
But, I do really need to push it and
be able to sell that story.
And it is a lot more.
- Have you considered pre-selling product?
- Yes, I have completely.
But the problem is, is
that I need to be able to
hunt that manufacturer
down and do what I need to.
- Well listen, don't fear pre-selling.
Don't fear it, because if
God forbid you can't make it,
you can return the money
and do something nice,
because you weren't able to deliver.
- Sure, sure.
- Right?
So, all of a sudden, God forbid you can't,
maybe you send back the
money and you design
a little handkerchief by
hand and send it to them.
Do you see what I mean?
- Yeah.
- So don't fear it.
- Do you think it's a good idea,
because my idea of doing this pre-selling
Kickstarter campaign was to do it directly
straight through my official website,
rather than doing something
like a Kickstarter?
- I like that.
- Yeah, I think you can do it on fucking,
you could do it on
fucking Instagram and post
a photo of it, of the
design, of one that you made
and absolutely crush that way too.
- Okay, cool.
I mean, that's awesome.
Thank you.
- I call that ghetto Kickstarter.
You just post it on Instagram
and say DM me if you want it.
- Word.
- Straight up.
You know what I mean?
It also builds community that way.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- Can I also follow in another question?
- Real quick.
- What kind of advice
would you have for someone
that has literally zero
business experience
and is a designer, artist background.
- There's two things.
One, you bring in a business partner,
and you actually give her or him a
percentage of the business.
- Okay.
- Or two, you realize that Tommy Hilfiger
and Tom Ford and many
others didn't have it
either and fucking
figured it out over time.
- Word, cool.
- Michael Kors figured
it out along the way.
- Right.
That's kind of what I'm hoping.
- Did you have any
entrepreneurial skills as a kid?
Like sell a blowpop, have lemonade,
like is it in you at all do you think?
- I mean, from the time
that I was out of the womb
I've known I was going
to be a fashion designer.
- That's amazing.
- And that drive that moves me,
but as I kind of went through F.I.T.
and my graduate studies,
it has been my,
the way I design is a
lot about marketability
and saleability in my design.
It's not about artsy shit, you know?
So, I am not an entrepreneur
but I have a business--
- You have a commercial capability.
- Exactly, exactly.
- You're, hopefully you'll
be in a position where you
can hire around your weaknesses,
whether that's your board
to do the accounting,
or things of that nature.
But if you find yourself,
you're so young still,
you can find yourself
in two or three years,
that you need to bring
in a business partner,
then that's what you do.
- Yeah, I mean that's the absolute dream,
is to be able to do that.
I'm like really working sunset to sunrise,
or the other way around.
- Never, never, never
compromise your story.
You got very lucky that
this pandemic happened,
because it gave you another
chance to not compromise.
- Sure, right.
I appreciate that very much.
- Awesome.
- Have a good day.
- You too, bye-bye.
It's a really good tea session.
I really, really like it.
Paul Hutchinson in the building.
He's sharing.
Devin Alexander always sharing.
Easter, he gets a follow.
I'm follower 656, for my man Lee.
Out in Topcliffe, England.
I appreciate everybody
sharing the screenshots
it's really, really cool.
I see all the screenshots,
and I am absolutely, absolutely.
Extra credit for Facebook
links, because I retweet those.
Retweet the ones that are
putting the Facebook links.
Derek Morgan, and Dean Carver
just got some new audience.
Oh, a LinkedIn link.
Gotta give Charlie a little tweet there.
See what else is happening here.
All right, Dustin what's going on?
We got a little delay?
- [Dustin] No, I was just waiting on you.
- Oh, I'm ready, go.
I'm ready, go, thank you so much.
Cool.
Aiden is on.
- Aiden what's good?
- Gary.
(laughing)
- Where you from bro?
- Connecticut.
- Awesome, what can I help you with?
- So, I'm a junior in
high school right now
and obviously we're having all the junior
planning and all that, right now.
It's online now too.
- Yeah.
- So, I don't think I
want to go to college.
And I know you don't have
like a positive or negative
view on college necessarily.
- Correct, I have a self-awareness view.
It is for some, it is not for others.
- Yeah.
- I really hate it for
people that it's not for
who collect debt,
that scares the shit out of me.
I love it for people that need it
to get the degree to do their passion
because they wanted to be
a doctor their whole lives.
So, it's definitely a, it's
not a one size fits all game.
And then I also worry about the pressure
of parents who think it's the only way.
- Yeah.
My parents, they are not
going to make me do anything.
But it's like the counselors and all that
telling me to go.
- Well good news, the
counselors are people
we least have to worry
about, fucking counselor.
Sorry Susan.
You know, okay.
- Yeah, so how I've made my money since
I was young, I mean I
umpired for a little bit
that was the only job that I've ever had,
like for somebody.
And then from there, I rake yards,
now I do landscaping and all that.
I just started a virtual
tour company for realtors.
- Interesting.
- So, tying that into
the whole college thing,
I always thought of it like,
If I can make a certain
amount of money per month
before I have to decide.
- That would be the decision.
- Yeah.
Is that a good way to look at it?
- It's a great way to look at it.
Especially if you keep your finances down.
Especially if your parents are willing
to let you live in your home.
Then you're fucking set.
Because you almost need no fucking money.
Or, if you got four other
buddies that are going
to the local college or a college by you,
or not college that you can crash with,
so that you can keep your expenses down.
Like, I think that the shit hole house
with four ambitious kids is
like an incredible environment.
Right, so you got to make
sure you're going into
a house with other hustlers,
not the local community
college where all the kids
fucking just don't give
a fuck about anything.
- Yeah.
- So, your environment
has got to be proper.
I think the other thing to think about is,
I do think there is an
emergence of kids like you
getting jobs for guys and gals like me.
So, one of the things I've been thinking
a lot about, for example,
marketing is something you'll always need.
So, is it better for you
to work at Vayner Media
for 40k a year and
commuting from Connecticut
two hours every day,
and learning for two or
three years, stealing,
taking, not stealing, taking
that skill and applying
that to your business, oh by the way,
news alert, you're only 21 now.
So, I've been thinking a lot about,
you know how I say get close to the sun,
I don't know if you've
ever heard me say that.
But go work for the person
you want to be like.
For example, if you like fell
in love with landscaping,
can you do a months work
of homework and find
seven or eight guys and gals who built
the best landscaping
businesses from scratch.
From being a kid that mowed a lawn,
and could you like cold
DM them, LinkedIn them,
and email them and say, I
want to be your apprentice.
I'll come and work for nothing,
and grind for a year,
but I'd like to learn.
And there in like
Alabama, and you're here.
And then you go down there for a year.
Do you see where I'm going?
There is different college,
where you get paid,
to fucking learn wisdom
that might take you 15 years
to learn your own way, but you actually
get paid to learn that wisdom over
the course of two or three years.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- You need to go work for an entrepreneur,
and you need to tell that entrepreneur,
I'm here, I'm going to get paid dick,
I'll get paid very little,
but I'm here to learn.
So, please can we have
drinks or a coffee once
every two weeks, because
I know you're busy.
And you can give me 10 minutes of wisdom,
and I ask you questions of observations.
Can I be your assistant?
Aiden, one of the greatest jobs
in the world is to be the admin assistant,
you know to a fucking
winning entrepreneur.
You will will learn so much, it's uncanny.
- Admin assistant.
- Yeah, just literally
be someone's assistant.
If you were my assistant,
you would learn more
in six fucking months,
then you would learn in business
school in your whole fucking life.
- Yeah.
- So, being the assistant
of a entrepreneur
might be a great job for you at 18.
Where you're getting paid
36, 41, 52, 27k a year.
Get fucking working in Google calender
and picking up cleaners,
and getting coffee.
But fucking, when you're that close,
you're learning at a level that's insane.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome brother, good luck.
- Thank you, see you.
- Talk to you soon.
That assistant life, I'm
telling you right now,
for so many of you wannabe entrepreneur's.
That assistant life is a game-changer.
If you're an organized fucker,
and you want to be an entrepreneur,
I couldn't recommended you more to
be the assistant of somebody,
instead of a bullshit job
or going to college.
If that's where you want
to be and that's where you
think you are, an organized
kid with big ambition,
can crush it, crush it.
I agree Branleemo, this
is an on-fire session.
I think that this is a
real good session today.
- Let's keep it going with Jamal.
- What's up Gary?
- Life's good bro, how are you?
- I am great.
I really hope that Aiden
is still on because
it's crazy because that you
started talking about that,
because I'm literally a product
of what you've been saying.
- Tell me, here we go,
I love the serendipity.
Tell me right now, tell me the story.
- So you, Gary Vee, for
anybody that's watching,
got me kicked out of Bible college.
Listening to Gary Vee.
(laughing)
- Was it the cursing?
- No, it's totally
cool, it's totally cool.
But, about four or five years ago,
I was in Bible college, studying,
I was actually studying
secondary education
and then everybody has to have like a core
of biblical studies.
Everybody is basically a double major.
Essentially, I wanted to either
be a high school teacher,
or I wanted go out and be a youth pastor,
and just really have fun with kids,
play games, like who
doesn't want to do that?
Who doesn't want to be the guy that
gets to play games and like teaching kids.
And so, about a year in,
I found just a random
video of yours and started
listening to your content.
And, I feel like God and life was like,
Okay, you don't want to
do what this man's saying,
so we're about to force you to do it.
And it was right around the
time where you were talking
about that whole self-evaluation thing.
If college isn't for you,
don't run yourself into debt.
Go back home, and live with your mom.
Go stack your money, figure
out what you're going to do.
I was hearing it, but I
was so scared to do it.
- Scared of it, of course.
It takes courage to
live the life you want.
- You know, like I'm 18 years old,
I just moved from Milwaukee, Wisconsin
to Chicago, Illinois.
You know, so I'm in this big city.
Our college is literally
smack dab down town Chicago.
So I'm like, go back home?
It took enough courage for
me to leave home to get here.
- I ain't going back to fucking Milwaukee.
- Right!
So I'm like, what the heck, you know.
I will never forget getting a call one day
from the school, like hey, you got to go.
I was like what?
They were like yeah, you got to go.
Basically my parents went
through a nasty divorce,
they agreed to paying for it,
because the school didn't
take certain loans,
and it wasn't expensive, it
was a tuition free school.
But you paid for room and boarding,
you're supposed to pay out of pocket.
They agreed to paying for that,
but it became kind of like
a rift in the divorce thing.
So got a call, I knew nothing.
So, they call me and they're like,
you can't come back.
My mom is like, just come home.
I'm like, no I'm not going to come home.
Basically I was homeless for six months.
Slept on people's couches.
Couch hopped from place to place.
Literally, when the
school year started back,
one of my old friends,
his roommate never came.
So, I literally squatted in his room.
And snuck around the campus,
because I still had my old ID.
And literally I got a job
as a call center worker.
And that gave me a enough
money to find my own place,
kind of get on my own feet.
I found a church, that at that time,
was super, it was on the rise,
because they were using
periscope at that time.
Periscope just shot them up.
And I found them via periscope.
Long story short man,
got offered $200 bucks to be the intern
for the senior pastor CEO.
He's not just a pastor,
he's a businessman,
he has multiple different businesses.
200 bucks a month to do
a freaking full-time job.
And I did it.
I did it while still
working at that call center.
I was in the call center answering phones,
and like responding to emails
and like scheduling meetings.
- Love you.
- You want a meeting,
okay, give me one second.
Okay, let me finish here.
- Jamal, hold on one
second, hold one second.
For everybody's that is listening,
every time that I bring up
the 28k to be the admin,
take the 42k to be the admin.
This motherfucker was
making 200 bucks a day,
like please, people are so entitled.
People are so soft.
If you want your dream, it should be hard.
I had a big dream, of course
it was fucking difficult.
- Yeah.
I did that for 3 years Gary.
- Say it one more time
for the people in the back
that didn't hear.
How long?
- I did that for three years.
Three years.
- I get it.
- And I did the internship,
lasted about six months.
And then they came to
me and they were like,
hey, do you want to do this full-time?
And I was like, oh yeah,
this is, okay great.
I don't have to work at
the call center, yeah cool.
And I was thinking like, I'm going to get
offered at least as much as I
get paid at the call center.
But it's a church.
You know, and so I literally
got offered $27,000
to come work full time at this church,
as a personal assistant, and I did it man.
And I did it for like I said, three years.
And a year and a half ago,
I got a phone call from my boss,
and he randomly, out of nowhere,
was like, "Hey, do you want
to be our next youth pastor?"
Which is what I went to school for.
It's literally what I
was going to school for.
Got kicked out of school,
studying to become this guy
that could spend his time
dealing with teenagers and helping kids,
and now we're actually one
of the largest churches
here in Chicago.
And I have 400 kids that
I'm responsible for.
And I was able to see it because,
I wasn't afraid to.
So if Aiden is still watching man,
don't be afraid.
- I'm proud of you Jamal.
I'm really proud of you.
I admire you.
- Thank you Gary.
Thank you so much.
It goes into my question though.
When I watch these, like
I was watching yesterday.
I got my tea in my little Christmas mug.
- Let's go.
(laughing)
- When I'm watching,
I feel like I hear the
same questions and I know that
you just get it out there.
But I'm one of those people,
as you can see with my story,
I love my nine to five.
You know.
I want to get better at that.
So like I told you, I have 400 kids alone.
Teenagers alone, that I'm responsible for.
Plus their parents that
look to me for advice.
- Guidance.
- I'm newly married for about a year now.
- Congratulations.
- Me and my wife don't even have kids yet.
But I have parents coming to
me for like parenting advice.
- Of course.
- And then I have team
members who are all like
different types of ages.
I'm 23.
What advice you give for
leading that many age groups.
At a young age.
- Couple of things.
You know, you were built for it.
At 23, I was ready to be a CEO.
If COVID happened when I was 23,
I would've lead it.
I lead it during 9/11.
When I was 25, you know,
what I would say to you
is a couple of things.
One, you're going to
continue to live this life.
Like some shit is just written.
Do you know what I mean?
So A, I actually think the single biggest
ingredient for you to be
successful in communicating
to these different
constituents, is humility.
It's very easy to get
high on your own supply.
You're getting all this
admiration, attention.
You're humbled by it.
And thus you actually
have to deploy humility.
So, when you talk to Mr. Thomson,
you say, listen, first of all,
Mr. and Mrs. Thomson,
I don't have children.
And I admire you so much, so
this comes with no judgment.
What I'm seeing from little Ricky is this.
I'm closer to little Ricky's
age than I am to yours.
And I can associate with him.
And some of the stuff that I've seen him,
and I overheard a conversation that he
was having with Linda.
And so what you might want to consider,
this is where the humility comes in,
you see where I'm going?
You start the convo with the hedge,
what you might want to consider,
and I think, in that humility,
you'll find that balance
that you'll be able
to reach more people because of it.
Because at some level,
what ends up happening
to the 23 year olds Jamal,
the 23 year old Gary,
the 23 year old's that
are watching right now,
that also kind of have it like that,
is you can get real caught up,
real quick, and all of a
sudden you're coming across
audacious instead of coming
across with humility.
Humility my man, is the
most important ingredient,
and the gift of
communicating with the hedge.
Even what I do now at 44, which is like,
and I'll say it right now, one more time
for anybody's that has never heard it.
I come across with conviction,
because I have conviction.
Which can come across as
over-confident, condescending.
I get it.
But let me say it one time,
right now for everybody.
These are my opinions and hypotheses.
This is what I see in business
and parenting in the world.
They are my opinions.
They are my observations.
They are my hypotheses.
I don't think I'm right.
I don't think I'm better.
I just think that this is experience.
I stay in a very narrow lane,
and this my hypothesis and observation.
And I think when people
can sense that humility.
They are more open to the
constructive criticism.
Or the strategy.
Jamal, at this gifted of a young age,
where people are looking to you.
Humility is your most important ally.
- Yeah, for sure.
And I got one more question,
just because I know you
talk about it a lot.
So, you've gotten it right
so many different times.
With Twitter, Facebook, Instagram.
I think you've like pre-said
so many different things.
I think you're next one
is really like TikTok,
that you've really been
talking about a lot.
I'm more of a, you know,
get on, talk, type of guy.
Motivator, type of person.
- Do that on TikTok.
- Okay.
- I have 3.3 million followers
on TikTok doing that.
- I just saw, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Cause I know when I get on.
- You don't need to dance.
You don't need to fucking dance.
- My kids are all like,
do that funny dance.
- Jamal, let me give you a history lesson.
All these platforms become
all kinds of content.
They start off.
You know what Instagram started off as?
Photography nerds.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
True, yeah.
- Taking fucking sunsets with a filter.
- Right, right, right, right.
- Facebook was college talk, hooking up.
Twitter was tech nerds.
- Yeah.
- They all start as something.
- True.
- And they all evolve to everything.
- I got you.
Will do.
Thanks so much Gary.
- Thank you Jamal.
Good shit with Jamal.
What a fucking Tea with Gary Vee episode.
I don't know if everybody is feeling it.
I am super feeling it.
Let me go to,
thank you Dustin for giving
me a few seconds here.
Let me go to the,
let's see what's going on.
Just wrote to Tom with
a cooperation proposal
for a platform that would be very helpful.
Thank you John.
Here is the quote of the day.
People pick the easy, faster, and money
over telling the story.
That's true Anthony.
I appreciate the people that
are putting out the quotes.
are putting out the links.
I think to Facebook.
Now, thank you Josh Jensen,
giving Jamal some love.
You get a follow for that Josh.
Order town to York, I appreciate that.
Josh Jensen, if you drink wine
I need you on winetext.com
I haven't done the winetext.com plug yet.
I promise my Dad every morning.
If you're watching right
now, and you buy wine.
At the shitty fucking
supermarket or the liquor store,
or even at total wine or Bevmo.
The single best way to
buy wine in the world,
is winetext.com
Besides empathywines.com, my winery,
the best way to buy wine in the world,
is winetext.com
You get a text, with a ridiculous deal.
It's like Groupon back in the day.
Today's wine I think is
$65 cabernet for 29 bucks.
Like they're stupid deals.
And then you just reply
with 2, 3, 4, or 5 bottles.
And you literally reply with a number.
- [Dustin] There's a little
banner underneath you too,
just so you know.
- Oh you have a banner?
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- Awesome, good job baby.
There it is.
It would mean the world to me.
It actually costs money to send a text.
So don't just sign up
to make me feel happy,
because we don't need it
if you don't buy wine.
But if you wine.
And definitely if you shop
at wine.com motherfucker.
If you're a wine.com buyer,
and you don't sign up for
winetext.com right now.
I'm done with you.
We're going to find your IP,
we're going to block you
from Tea with Gary Vee.
You're going to break
my little fucking heart.
If you fucking shop wine.com
if your wine is sold out,
or last bottle.
If you are not on winetext right now?
You broke my fucking heart.
Tell me if you signed up for
winetext right now on Twitter,
so I can follow you.
If you actually signed up
for winetext, right now.
Show me the screen that
shows the confirmation.
Some states are not allowed.
No Texas, no Chicago, Illinois excuse me.
So there's that.
All right Dustin, let's keep it going.
Man, Jamal was a great guest.
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- Thank you P. Andrew.
Cody!
- Gary.
- What's good?
- Dude, you got to get Alaska on board
with the winetext man.
I got two cases of the
all three coming in today.
But you got to hook up
Alaska with winetext.
- You know what it is?
The winetext thing is
so crazy because we are
selling like $70 wines for thirty,
or $25 dollar wines for
nine and the shipping
from New Jersey, we're
still a national player,
but we still don't have
a warehouse in Cali
or somewhere else where we can
mitigate the shipping cost.
Like, we just lose ungodly
fucking amounts of money
every time we ship to
Alaska, so we have to
take it off for now, but
we are working on it Cody.
And big love to you and
everybody in Alaska.
And thank you for supporting Empathy.
We're really, really proud of it.
- Man I'm so excited meeting you.
- Dude, I see you got the admit one poster
in the back there.
- Yeah dude, so I'm from Anchorage.
Movies are my life Gary.
Little bit of context.
I grew up here, I left
to go to film school
back in 2010, and I
managed to do my internship
back here in town, when
I worked on a Nic Cage
movie called Frozen Ground.
The stars aligned, my grandmother who
introduced me to film and
got me hooked on James Bond.
I got to say bye to her
when she passed away,
and I got to work on this
incredible movie set.
But, I love movies, Gary.
I've been writing movies
for several years.
- I feel it Cody.
I feel it.
- I've been paying off.
I went to 110k of debt down to,
after my next payment processes,
I'm down to 39.
- Proud of you.
- I've been living at
home for seven years.
- Proud of you.
- Grinding away.
I've been writing.
I'm live-action.
My best friend from film
school, he's animation.
About a year and a half, two years ago,
I pivoted with all the
emerging streaming platforms.
We think it's better to break
into kids animated content.
So, I've been writing
my live-action features.
I've been been helping him.
We've been writing kids TV shows together.
And story is king.
If you don't have drama,
you don't have shit.
But I obsess about everything with film.
Utilizing camera tricks
to push certain emotions,
depending on what's happening in the shot.
I love music, and how music
and score goes with the story.
I think about the color pallets,
I think about everything.
I just obsess about film.
I love film and movies so much.
But my big question to you is,
how do I leverage my
TikTok and my LinkedIn
posts so we can have more
leverage when approaching
the bigger streaming platforms.
We actually just got another
rejection from CBS Viacom.
Because my buddy he went
to the kids screen summit,
down in Florida last month.
And he was pitching our ideas
to tons of different companies.
And it's a great feeling to
know that Netflix and Disney
and Nickelodeon, Amazon are reading stuff
that I've written right now.
But I just need help finding leverage.
For when we approach those companies.
- Leverage comes through
character ideation and creation.
Then really building it
through development and getting
people to give a fuck.
I would tell you to get your
best bud from film school,
the animator, I think you need
to create Instagram accounts,
and TikTok accounts, and Twitter accounts
for the actual characters.
- Got them all.
- Cody, your passion is
so uncomfortably exciting
and COVID has given me a few
more minutes here and there
more than normal, so I want
you to send me an email.
To Gary@Vaynermedia and I'm
going to look at it tonight.
I want to see the characters.
Give me all the links,
let me see what I can do.
- Thanks Gary, I really appreciate it man.
- I also have pretty
significant relationships
at all the streaming companies,
and if I can get excited about something,
I might be able to move you
up the ladder dramatically
from the levels that you've
been kind of at at this point.
- I really appreciate it.
You know, it's a long hard grind.
And I did TikTok posts.
- Hey Cody.
- Yeah?
- Seven years on top of
four years is nothing.
You got it.
(stuttering)
Cody, can you do me a favor?
I love you.
Can you do me a favor?
I want you to read, today, just for fun,
I want you to read, google it.
I want you to read an
article about Vera Wang,
around Colonel Sanders, and a guy by the
name of Sydney Frank,
who created Grey Goose,
when he was 81 years old.
I think your passion is so,
I mean I'm sure right now on Twitter
everyone's like, I fucking
love this guy Cody.
You know like, your passion is so clear.
It's so endearing.
I just want to make sure
that you realize that it's
super early and I have a feeling
that you're so passionate about this,
that if you lived at home
for another 21 years,
that that film was finally made,
that you would be fulfilled.
And I think you have to
wrap your head around that.
It just changes everything
if you can go there.
Do me a favor Cody.
I'm going to say it again slow.
Vera Wang,
If I'm going to help you, and look at
these characters tonight and
introduce you to some people
at Netflix and Amazon, I need you to,
Vera Wang, and you got to find the article
or the Colonel Sanders, the
Kentucky Fried Chicken dude.
And a guy by the name of Sydney Frank.
I think it was Sydney,
but I could be wrong.
Sydney Frank.
He actually created Jagermeister,
so he had a success in
his 50's I think it was.
But 81.
He always wanted the big
one and it was Grey Goose.
And really that was when he made it.
So, I want you to like
read articles about them.
Their little autobiographies or whatever.
Just, I want that to go
into your fucking head.
The same way that James Bond did,
because I think it's an
ingredient that can take you
and be a foundational ingredient.
Kind of like James Bond and Grandma,
were the steak and listening
to stories about these people
is the lobster and I want you to kind of
surf and turf your life here a little bit.
I want that element.
And then I will take a look,
and before the end of next
couple of weeks, you'll hear from me,
and let me see and I'll
give you some feedback.
And I'm sure my team is
watching this right now,
I know DRock and others are
probably excited as well.
Some of them may jump in.
- Well, I really appreciate it Gary.
- All right Cody.
Cody, in the title put I'm
the film dude from Alaska
and I'll make sure I don't lose it.
- You got it.
- I wish you well.
Talk to you soon.
You're welcome very much.
All right, Cody bringing it.
I know there's going to
be some tweets about Cody.
Let's see what we got here.
There we go.
Kenobi is now part of winetext.
I like that screen.
I know, no Texas Blaze Pittman, I'm sorry.
See what's going on here.
I am on fire Kristen.
I appreciate that.
I was hoping for a
couple more sign-ups for,
there we go.
John Gold is in the building.
Appreciate you signing up.
Let's see, who else is here.
Josh Allen.
Just signed up.
Office Saint, my guy.
Where do you ship to?
It says in Ontario, I'm not sure that's,
Nick, what's good?
- Hey, how's it going?
- Really well.
- I've been following you
for like four years now,
so this is like crazy, like
talking to you right now.
- Thank you so much.
- Well, I'm just going to
give you a little context.
So, in high school I was
buying and reselling candy,
mowing grass, just doing stuff like that.
- Entrepreneur.
- I started buying and flipping stuff,
so I started going garage selling,
buying it and flipping stuff.
Started flipping on Ebay
and started to see numbers.
Like one to 2,000,
and then I started to flip phones.
That's what really made it take off.
I started to do 10k a month,
it was just like a big milestone for me.
Like 10k a month.
- A month?
- Yeah.
- That's real.
How much profit were
you making on that 10k?
30% so I remember my bank
account it went from like
2,000 to like five.
So, it was about 30%.
Like $3,000 profit.
So, I was planning on
moving to a bigger city.
Move in with my sisters
and stuff like that.
And growing, stuff like that.
But I met this guy.
This is pretty much my question.
I met this guy, and he was
a total opposite of me.
He's an extrovert, I'm
really more of an introvert.
So it just really worked.
You know, we teamed up
and we started Ecomm.
So now we're Amazon FBA wholesale,
we started Ecomm,
and the last 30 days
we're doing around 30k.
- What are you selling?
- Huh?
- So we sell, we're really
big in the video game niche.
We buy clothes out, so
we buy from distributors
and small brands and bigger distributors.
Just stuff like that.
- I like it, but keep going.
- My question is, I'm trying
to put this in a positive way.
I don't want to make this negative.
But my question is,
- It's not negative bro.
It's your life.
There's no negative or positive.
Just ask the question.
- So we've been bumping
heads a lot last year,
but we're kind of on a
standard ground right now,
but it doesn't feel genuine.
It just feels like we're
working together because
we really benefit from each other.
- Because the money.
What's the biggest grind between you two?
- It's probably more so about he has
different standards, he just wants--
- He's about the money at all costs?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Makes sense.
Extroverts, this is what
makes me a little unique.
I'm wildly extroverted, I'm that guy.
The reason a lot of people at first,
I don't know how you felt
when you first saw me,
but a lot of people at first, like a lot,
like 20% I would say of
people when they first see
a video of mine, are like
this guy is full of shit.
You know what I mean?
Because I've got that gift of gab,
and you got to be a little bit
cautious if that's your DNA.
A lot of people that have
that extroverted mentality,
unfortunately often,
not always, also have, you know,
that kind of like non-ethical,
like win at all costs,
like fuck everybody.
Who gives a shit?
Don't return their money.
You know, just some of that shit.
- Yeah.
- So, that's common.
So, do you feel like
that's a little bit of
that kind of thing and where you're like
a little bit on the straight and straight?
- Yeah, and it just feels like all this
superior type of thing,
like everything is a competition,
and sometimes I just like
keep things to myself,
because I don't want to share it.
- Got it, because he's
like well I did this,
and I did better than what you did,
kind of thing?
- Yeah, a little bit.
But it also feels like, you know,
last year we did 132,000
and for the most part,
it just feels like I did everything.
So it's just like,
Because I'm a computer
guy, so emails, anything,
I'm on top of it.
Like stuff like that.
Any small fires that
happen in the business,
I'm always putting them out.
- So you're the operational part.
- Basically, yeah.
- So, what's he bring to the table?
- The people that he
brings into our business,
more so like connections with
other big Amazon sellers,
and we get inside stuff.
It's just we get a lot,
I get a lot of ideas
and stuff like that.
- And who finds the product?
- I do.
(sighs)
- This is a tricky one.
Here's what I would say.
Like any relationship,
communication's the only thing that works,
and when you stop communicating,
and to your point, it's on some fake shit,
it's always vulnerable,
and eventually it's going to die.
So I think, and by being an introvert,
it might be hard for you to step up
and like call for that dinner
once this COVID shits done,
or you might be together, I don't know.
You know call for that dinner,
and just really talk it out.
And be like, "Yo, this is
mutually beneficial financially,
"but it might not be mutually
beneficial psychology wise."
"And happiness wise."
And probably ultimately then won't
be that beneficial financially.
"Can we talk this through
and maybe it's just on some"
"we got to share with each other shit,"
"or should we just split up and move on"
"and we'll both be happier,
this was a great chapter."
"We got love or each
other, and like let's go."
- Okay, okay.
- That is the answer.
- Okay, now last thing is,
do you think that I'm foolish?
So, in December, all my business partners
we flew down to LA, we
rented out a penthouse,
and we rented exotics, and
took brand new pictures.
- So it looked like you guys were
flossing more than you were?
I mean you've been listening
to me for four years.
You know the answer.
You know I hate that
shit more than anything.
- Yeah.
So, it just--
- It fucked you up?
- Yeah.
- Now, you said all us business partners.
So, you got other business
partners beside dude.
Yeah, it's just one other.
He brings money to the table.
- Look, it sounds like
those guys, potentially,
and I don't overly judge,
but based on the picture
that you are painting,
they like the idea of the
entrepreneurial lifestyle,
and back to you saying
other Amazon leaders.
Like they may be caught up in the game,
and want to be the other
cool Amazon resellers
and the entrepreneurs they
see on fucking Instagram.
You know the bizarro
reverse versions of me.
That think the model
life, the bottle life,
the jets life, the fucking
exotics and penthouse life.
It just doesn't sound
like you're about that.
- Yeah.
I mean, that's basically it.
- Nick, nick.
This situation is not long-term for you,
and that's okay too.
Like, sometimes a
girlfriend, sometimes a job,
sometimes a hobby is a moment in time.
It's a stepping stone into the next thing.
I think what you need to do is try to end
it graciously, and I
think the way you do that
is by having an authentic conversation.
- Okay.
- And that's hard.
I have not been great at
that in my career at times.
So I'm giving you advice
that's hard for me.
It's easier for others.
But, you know, my dad's good at it.
He'll shoot it.
My brothers good at it.
I'm not great at it.
It's tough to have the courage to be like,
"Yo John, let's have this talk."
"I'm not about that same life."
"I'm not sure if this is long-term."
"Can we talk this out?"
"I don't like this, I don't
like this, I don't like this."
That comes hard for me, but I
know it's the answer for you.
And hopefully you can do it.
- Yeah, on a personal level,
they have come to me on personal stuff,
and I've really like, helped them out.
So it's like I do care for them,
and I always trying to hang.
- And that's what I' saying.
I'm saying, like too
many people think when
a partnership isn't good anymore,
that it has to burn to the ground
and it has to be on some lawyer shit,
and anger shit, and
forever no talking shit.
It can be good.
- Okay.
- And if they think they're
the magic of it all,
they may think, or he may think
that well this is good,
I can find some other
person to handle the
emails and the shipping.
Like, a lot of times the charismatic one
thinks the operations one is replaceable.
- Okay.
Makes sense.
All right.
- Good luck my man.
Have that conversation, have it.
Have it.
Please rewatch this video over and over
until you can, do you think you can do it?
Do you think you can have the
real, real, real, real, talk?
You think you've got that in you?
- Yeah, we had talks before
and that's why I'm saying
like, we are on common
grounds, but it's more
of so where you're kind of
using each other right now.
And every phone call is like the business,
and we're also trying to get stuff done,
stuff like that.
But it's like at the same time,
it just doesn't feel genuine.
- I love that.
I love you.
I love you for knowing
that's what you need.
And so like, go.
Go.
Take a step back, financially
and take two steps forward,
five steps forward happy wise,
and then financially.
- Okay.
- All right Nick, take care of yourself.
That's a good one.
Man we're just over half way.
Fuck, do you guys understand
how this fucking show is?
Like, do we love this show?
Do you guys love this fucking show?
Fuck man.
Like, I feel like Tea with
Gary Vee takes a big shit
on the ask Gary Vee show Dustin.
- [Dustin] Yeah, I agree.
- Now, I miss India and
Steve and all the jokes
and entertainment value,
but this is like, I tend to bring
entertainment and information.
It's kind of like a 50/50 or a 60/40.
This one feels like 90 fucking just steak.
- [Dustin] Yeah, I agree.
And it's just definitely more context
and going back and forth,
clear things up better.
- I'm not rushed, which
gives me, you know?
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- Yeah, love it.
Let's keep it going.
Big shout out to Eric
Holkren for sharing the show.
Grand Rapids, Michigan,
you just got a follow.
If you want to get on it.
Let me see if I can,
Hold on one second, give me one second.
- [Dustin] Sure.
- I'll be right there,
I'll be right there.
Be right right you Marley.
If you want to get some follows,
here it is, share the screenshot
and the link to Facebook
or LinkedIn, and we
will give you some love.
Josh Allen, thank you so much.
Marley!
- Hey Gary, thank you so much
for taking my question today.
- Happy to do it.
- So, just a little bit
of backstory about me,
I'm in Memphis, Tennessee
and I'm a corporate event planner.
And as you can imagine
with COVID-19 epidemic,
has really hit us hard.
Lucky for us, we don't
only do in-person events
we also do fulfillment
and cuts and shipping.
And then we also do
sourcing for premium items,
and then we also do virtual events.
So we're really just trying to figure out
what is the narrative of like, okay,
we still obviously want
to do in person events
after this but to get us
through this time right now,
and just not knowing when
it's going to be over,
how we overcome this barrier right now.
That's where we are really at.
I'm just trying to convert those.
- You need to build brand right
now for prospective clients,
when you're on the other side.
I mean this is real shit.
You know, I've lost seven
figures in public speaking
and performance events,
and it's not coming back.
So, what am I doing?
Continuing to put out content
and continue to build brands.
So, when we get on the other side of it,
you know, somethings, they have been using
a lot of war terminology
on mainstream media
and things of that nature,
there's some truth to that.
Right, with businesses and if this 1940's
and World War II is like
starting to pop off,
and you're asking me how
do you get through this,
and when all the boys in the
company just went off to Europe.
The answer is you don't.
Sometimes the answers you don't.
And I think the one
move we all have Marley,
is to build brand.
So Q and A shows, LinkedIn, Whitepapers,
16 tips on how to become a great
public speaker that gets paid,
as a LinkedIn post, maybe a good idea.
Right, like things that company,
four tips that a company
should think about
when they put on an event.
Like just information.
Acting like an editorial machine,
is probably the way right now.
Because, really storytelling
and valuable information
is the only thing you can do right now,
because other than put
on and operate as many
virtual events, because the reality is,
this is where we are.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So when you're talking
about going out and being
subject matter and
telling stories right now,
what platform do you think
is the best to use that,
or do it on all platforms?
- All of them.
Too many people want to
pick the right platform,
like for you, honestly,
like LinkedIn is a monster.
It's a monster.
So I think LinkedIn is
something your company
has to get great at.
3, 4, 5, 6, pieces of
content a day on LinkedIn,
is something that I would recommend.
- Okay, and like that
or just like us talking?
- Yeah, but it's editorial, right.
It's not promotion.
Too many people go into infomercial
and I want them to go into New York Times,
I want them to go into Consumer Reports,
I want them to go into the Wine Spectator.
I want them to bring value.
- Yeah.
- So, notice how my examples
were for the audience,
not for the sales funnel for you business.
- Absolutely and so I
guess with my business,
it's more of like we're
a creative industry,
and we're paid a lot
of times on our ideas,
how you kind of go between giving away
all your ideas, and still
create a brand for yourself.
- Give them away.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- Marley, I give away all my ideas.
The world is abundant.
You giving out your idea is
going to lead to the customer.
Is some other Marley in
Texas going to take that
and run with it, yes.
It's not coming out of your pocket.
It's the greatest confusion of all time.
The world is abundant, and your best ideas
lead to business, not lead
to somebody stealing it
and losing business.
It's the greatest confusion
in the business world.
- Okay, makes sense.
- Awesome, good luck.
Have a great day.
- Thank you so much Gary, appreciate it.
- You're welcome, have a great day.
Moses James James, you
get a follow my guy.
I am your 378th follower.
You are in Nigeria.
I got a lot of love for the
entrepreneurship in that world.
Let's do it.
Appreciate it Steven Barnhart.
Kevin.
- What's going on Gary?
Man, I could not even sleep last night
knowing I was going to talk with you man.
You've changed my life.
- Thank you bro, how so?
- So, about five months
ago, my buddy Brandon and I
we started up a TikTok
called fantasy freaks.
I'm repping the shirt right now.
And we talk fantasy
football and pretty much
football in general.
And at the time, it was like,
okay, who's on TikTok pretty much.
Comedy videos, Dance videos, and Gary Vee.
So it's pretty scary
to start posting about
fantasy football, something
we're super passionate about.
And, we decided.
- But you did it because I
was pushing, pushing, pushing.
- I mean oh, you were
just saying okay do it,
and I was like okay, fuck it.
Let's just,
I'm a freshman in college,
I'm from Columbus, Ohio.
And I was like all right,
we're going to spend our
Friday nights making
16 NFL breakdown videos
for every game, we're
posting 16 videos straight.
It takes three hours, four hours,
and I'm like let's just do it.
So we did it.
We were kind of grinding.
We've seen a lot of linear growth.
And we're up to 230,000
followers right now
on TikTok, and it's
literally all because of you
saying you can take your
passion and turn into TikTok
success and you can grow on social media.
And I can't even tell you how much it's
changed my life.
You know, it's so awesome.
But, we have a really strong following,
pretty much a younger demographic.
So kind of like the eight
to 16 year old range.
So, I guess my question is,
we're super passionate about this.
We love to have it as
a career in the future.
How do we take like our
following on TikTok,
and turn it into a profitable business.
- You're in the best spot ever.
First of all, you have four
more years before you have to.
You're going to finish school.
- Yeah, no rush.
I'm in no rush at all.
- Kevin, you fucking won.
Your audience is going to be of the age
where they'll be willing to buy something,
right at the time,
like not only do you have
these next three and half years
of college, but then you also have
the fact that you're still fucking 22,
and you and your buddy and go and fucking,
you know where I'm about to go.
Room with three other
fucking knuckle heads,
fucking eat McDonald's all day,
and be fucking set.
You've probably got,
what I think you should do is what I did,
is not monetize them.
Like build the fucking
audience at all costs.
Then let's have this
discussion in four years.
- Okay, people are always asking,
"are you guys getting paid yet?"
and we're like, we don't need the money.
- Don't listen to those people.
- I'm not taking on any college debt.
I'm in no rush to make any money,
and my audience is really young,
I don't even know how much
money they are willing to spend
on a package for advice.
- It's a stupid conversation.
No.
You are not allowed to ask for money.
Do not think about a
dollar for four years.
Here's why.
And that's a very different
answer that we gave earlier
to Tom, who needs to make
5 bucks from everybody.
It's because you have the luxury,
the privilege, thank God,
the serendipity to not.
Which put's you in the power position.
- Yeah, no it's a good spot.
- No, no, no.
No, no, no.
It's the best spot.
And when the day comes
in four or five years,
there might be fucking
augmented reality filters,
there may be some new piece of
clothes that we put the logo on.
Bro, we don't know what the fuck's
going to happen in four years.
- I know.
Well, I always talk to my
buddy Brandon about it,
I'm like, you know even
if it's not football,
if we can find the next thing to elevate
fantasy football or
whatever it is at that time,
we'll be able to have a
following that loves football,
that loves pretty much
everything about us.
Because we're building us up too.
- You're set.
100% brand building.
100% brand building for the
next three and a half years.
100% brand building.
- Yeah, I'm in no rush.
I don't need the money.
- No, no, it's about even spending
even a second debating it.
From this moment on, just
like the TikTok thing
that I pushed you, no more minutes.
I'm more worried about,
watch this.
How many followers do
you have on Instagram?
- So that's the question.
We wanted to push TikTok first,
and take advantage of that
organic reach kind of.
- Correct, correct.
How many followers do
you have on Instagram?
- I have 300, and 2,000 on Twitter.
- Right, 300 on Instagram, 200 on Twitter?
- 2,000 on Twitter.
But yeah, we're still growing a lot.
- This is where I was going.
Notice how I asked the question.
I know exactly where you are at.
You're part of this new
generation that listened to me,
crushed on TikTok,
instead of worrying about
fucking selling them
some bullshit fucking $9
draft guide, or a fucking t-shirt,
what I want you to do is
now add two pieces a content
a day on TikTok, that has the sole purpose
to drive people to follow
you on Instagram on Twitter.
- Okay, so Instagram, Twitter.
Thought's on YouTube?
- Yep!
Yep!
- Okay.
Because I'm always like is
it worth putting in my time
to other social media
platforms when I could
really just push this growth on TikTok.
- Both.
- Just do it all?
- Yeah bro.
- Balance the college
student, balance the TikTok,
the Instagram, the twitter.
- Yep!
- Okay.
- More!
You have a moment in time.
This TikTok thing is going to go away.
- Just like Vine kind of.
- No, no, no, I apologize.
I don't think it's going
to go away like Vine.
It might.
- The growth?
- You're saying.
- The growth.
- The reach?
- The reach bro!
Like, you've already seen it.
- Yeah, no, especially
these past couple of weeks
it's gone down, you've probably
seen it on your page too.
- I have.
Because I've been consistent about this.
It's a land grab.
- Yeah.
- And so, the early people go.
You can't be Charley anymore.
There's too many people on it.
You can be fucking humongous.
- We are first in our niche.
Which is like a big thing I think.
- First is great, and I'm glad about 230,
but best always will matter in the end,
but most of all, listen to me,
and listen to me good.
Two pieces of content a day.
One for Twitter, one for LinkedIn.
All the ideas, all this energy that
you think about how to monetize,
all goes away and it all goes
into the creation of creative,
that is built for the
intent to follow on Twitter.
Giveaways.
On TikTok, hey guys for
everybody that follows us
on Twitter right now, and you
use hashtag fantasy freaks,
we're going to pick two of you randomly
and we'll go on zoom with you
for 15 minutes and talk football.
For your fan base, that's exciting.
All of a sudden, you tripled
your number on Twitter,
on one fucking TikTok extra post a day.
- That's awesome.
That's awesome.
I'm going to grind it out.
I promise.
- I believe you.
- All right, thanks so much Gary.
- You're welcome brother.
Fucking dropping fucking gems and keys,
and whatever the fuck you want to call it,
on Tea with Gary Vee.
I'm fucking at it today.
I'm feeling it.
You know what I love
about this show Dustin?
Is that motherfuckers don't realize
how smart I am at this shit.
They just think that I'm
loud and charismatic.
I fucking know the game Dustin.
- [Dustin] 100%.
- I'm Yoda in this bitch.
Juan, what's good?
- Hey Gary.
How are you?
- How are you?
- I'm from Spain, so
sorry about my English.
(laughing)
- No problem, no problem.
(mumbling)
- I am super excited and super
thankful for this opportunity.
Talking to you.
I am international, so
we don't have the access
of the text community and stuff.
So, super, super, super good.
- Happy to be here.
- My question.
You're the only person I
have on Google notes thing.
- Thank you.
- With my questions, I have it for like
one and a half years ago.
- Thank you.
- My question is like, it comes from
some of the things that
you have said these
past two years, these past days.
To give you like contextual.
You talk about like how it's
good not to be an expert,
and I really like to think about
the journey to becoming a chef.
That kind of clicked.
But, I feel like that works
when you have that goal
of becoming a chef.
You know, so in my
case, I am 22 years old.
My interest is in cars.
- Cars.
- Yeah, I an studying
engineering for it and stuff,
and I consume a lot of
cars and stuff like that.
But I feel like I'm young,
I don't have the driving
experience that other people
have with real work engineering.
Experience in the field.
That the people that I follow
and the people that I admire have.
So, I feel like if I were
to put out content now.
I would just be rehashing their takes.
Their experience, and would
be judged like doing that.
- Juan, do you know what a DJ is?
(laughing)
- So, I think of those
engineers as songwriters
as rappers as artists,
and I think of you right now at 22 or 20,
having that ability to be a DJ.
So to your point, you're a very smart kid
for picking up on, I
thought in the whole week
and a half with Tea with Gary Vee,
that piece of advice I
gave about documenting
the journey of becoming the
thing that you want to be,
was one of the two or
three best things I said.
So thank you for picking up on that.
I think you can do that.
And I think the way you do that,
to your point,
because when you're doing
the chef, you can do it,
but when you talk about engineering,
it's hard to show that,
because you can't quote unquote do it.
- I start like practicing
and stuff like that.
- I think you need to
think about being a DJ,
I don't know if you've seen on TikTok,
where people have a video on green screen,
like I have this background
and they talk over it.
I like the idea of you making
videos or writing articles,
that take something that somebody said,
and then you give your
youthful hypothesis.
- Yeah, so that was my thing.
I know I can write stuff, but my biggest
struggle is the value
proposition of that, you know?
Where is the value?
- The value proposition
comes in one observation.
One agreement, one disagreement.
One, have you thought of,
I loved Juan Pablo said, but
has he thought about this?
If you're right, one time, you win.
I'll give you an example.
When I was a wine kid at 16,
I thought that Australian
and New Zealand wines
should be bigger.
So, I could've wrote articles
or made videos saying
I think one day Australian wines and
New Zealand wines will be bigger.
I ended up being right.
Something you write today,
that ends up happening
in 11 years, might be the
LinkedIn article that you wrote
that gets you a job or a
bigger job when you're 31.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
And yeah, if you're wrong
don't be afraid of being wrong.
- Wrong is good.
Wrong is good.
Wrong's not, nobody's going
to stop from hiring you
for being wrong at 22,
everybody's going to hire you
for being right at 22.
- Yeah, makes sense.
And one last question.
From my long list.
(laughing)
It's a short one.
It's like how do you
leverage your softness.
Is there a way to,
you also talk about, you know,
this kid Jamal from before,
he's worked in a call center for 3 years,
he's been in the hardships.
I haven't.
I live with my parents.
My parents pay for everything.
I'm super grateful for that.
My dad has worked super hard,
he works from home but you know,
but he's been through tough stuff.
My mother as well.
But I haven't.
- Well good news, you will.
Unfortunately for all of us, life is hard
and maybe just because at this point
you've been very fortunate,
doesn't mean eventually
you will not have hardship.
You can't fake hardship.
What you need to lean into
is gratitude right now.
Right?
And, what you can do is
put yourself in a position
to build on your own two feet.
So you could get a job.
You could.
Or, you take advantage of this moment,
when it's going well,
and you do do what we just talked about.
And produce an ungodly amount of content
with your thoughts and
dreams and observations
around other people's work as a DJ.
So, you know, don't beat yourself up
because thank God, has
put you in a spot where
we don't control who our parents are,
who we've been born into,
and what circumstance
we've been born into.
You will have your
hardships and that is life.
And right now, take advantage
of it not being as hard
and produce this content.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
I feel like the hardship is in the dome.
Like how you talk about.
There's people who have it
tough, but a strong mentality
and maybe it will help us.
I've been lacking one way and
the other maybe not so much.
- I understand.
- You're a dope man.
- You're welcome Juan.
Thank you so much.
You're a very thoughtful kid.
I wish you a great future.
I love this fucking show.
Tea with Gary Vee.
I'm going to have to figure out,
sucks when COVID is over,
I'm going to have to go back to,
I'm going to have to fucking hack it.
Just got to you know.
Just a lot of fun right now.
- [Dustin] We can still
make it work when we're back
in the office and stuff.
- Yeah, but you know how that shit is.
- [Dustin] True.
- Scott Hughes with 15,000 follower plus,
that's a nice little following.
Middle town, Ohio.
I appreciate you sharing the show brother.
- All right Kaitlyn.
- Can you hear me?
- Way better form.
I love it, how are you?
- Great, great.
So, thanks for having me on.
My question is kind of an interesting one,
and in that I'm not in
traditional entrepreneurship.
I've been pretty successful
in the medical device field,
and have been moving up as an executive.
But I struggle with how do
you move up in that executive
field without losing authenticity.
- You don't.
- When you move up in corporation,
you're playing politics.
It's the nature of the game.
Now, you don't have to.
I think you have to,
you know, there's a big difference between
a 100% transparent authenticity and
you know, really compromising
who you are in your soul.
Right?
- Okay.
- So, biting your tongue is something
that in life is just normal.
In entrepreneurship land or corporation.
Doing something that
compromises who you, you know,
doing something that
undermines somebody you think
that is competing with you for the job
that's only available to you or her,
or to you and him, and
like sabotaging them.
You know, that's compromising
who you are, right?
- Right.
- So, bad talking about
a competitive employee
that's trying to move up too,
that might be compromising who you are.
You know, selling something you
don't believe in is a problem.
- Right.
- That's compromising who you are.
So like, that's how you
have to navigate it.
- Right, I mean do you suggest like
for someone who just loves the process,
so I love the grind, I love working.
- I get it.
- Thank you so much.
- Do you think that it's better
to go into entrepreneurship
if you have that mentality?
- Not necessarily.
Entrepreneurship is a skill,
like also, there's just
some people who love being
the number two, seven, 12, 14 but as soon
as all the actual pressure
to make money is on them,
at all costs, and deal with COVID,
and deal with the building burning down,
and the best person quitting,
and somebody's stealing, and you know,
there is a stomach that comes
along with entrepreneurship.
You know, even when I
deliver all that stuff
just watching your face, I'm like,
well I think she may be able to do it.
If you don't frown on that, then yes.
Let me say this Kaitlyn.
You might, just even
listening to you right now.
You might just want to
try it so you don't have
regret when you're 92 and like
fuck, I should have tried.
- Yeah, because I kind
of started a side hustle,
and it got pretty successful
and I took a pause,
like I'm trying to do two things at once.
- Can you afford to not have the main job,
and go at something?
- Not quite yet, but I'm getting there.
- Can you change your lifestyle
to be able to get there?
- Yes.
- Or would you prefer, so
now the question becomes
would you prefer to change your lifestyle
because it's burning in your stomach,
and you got to start tomorrow,
or could you plan in for
another year of going hardcore savings,
that then gives you that air cover
for a year or what have you,
to go after it.
- Yeah, which I could, I could
probably do another year.
I think just the hard thing
is just giving up the need to win.
I want to win at everything.
- I fucking love it.
I mean listen, competition is a,
my competitive sprit is a
foundational to my success.
You know, then you should
look at your lifestyle.
- Yeah.
- When you want something, all of a sudden
four dollar coffees, all of a sudden,
three subscriptions that you're paying for
that you never fucking use.
All of a sudden, a lot of, man.
Outside of like the real
below the poverty line,
like I've been blown
away by people that make
35k a year emailing me, literally,
emailing me their credit card bills
and their other bills, photos of it,
and talking about how they
figured out how to save
$800 a month, and what it did for them.
Listen, the audience
that's watching right now,
every one of us fuckers is wasting money
on dumb shit that's holding
us back from happiness.
- Yeah.
That's true.
- Can you do your nails every
three weeks instead every week.
Can you stop buying fucking Starbucks.
It's that real.
There's so many little
hacks that could lead to,
and by the way, for a lot of people,
doesn't sound like for you thank God,
or for me, but for a lot of people,
they are in some scary
financial situations right now,
and they didn't fucking
listen to me about saving
and not spending money on dumb shit.
And now they are caught.
- Yeah.
- Yours is a little bit more
of a high class problem,
thank God, because you've got
the talent and worked hard,
which is, do you want to give
up some lifestyles right now,
to go right into it, or do you
want to have a real strategy
and like wait another
year, save up, heavy.
- Yeah.
- Between changing your
lifestyle and having the job,
and then go for it.
I think both are incredible options.
You've got time.
- Okay.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so
much Kaitlyn, take care.
- Bye.
Oh boy, this is really getting good.
This is really getting good,
I don't know what else to say.
Tea with Gary Vee.
- My man.
- [Dustin] This is Mark.
- Mark how are you?
- How are you doing Gary?
- I'm doing super well.
- Thank you for everything you do.
That's first thing.
- Thank you.
- Secondly I have a quick question,
I am a photographer as a side hustle,
my main hustle pays my bills and it does
what it needs to do for me.
But my side hustle is my passion.
It's photography.
I started a business, maybe
like a month and a half ago.
- Great timing.
- Right.
(laughing)
- The good news is that I
don't need the photography
to pay for my bills.
- Respect.
- It works out.
- Yes.
- My issue is that I'm in an area,
I'm in Connecticut that's for photography
it's not necessarily the most creative.
And also people are not
willing to pay as much
as my services, I feel
my services are worth.
- Why?
- Well, it's just the audience.
- Is it supply and demand,
or is it the income level?
- There is a supply and demand issue.
- Yeah, because there's just
so many fucking photographers.
- That is true.
- Gary you got to pay more
for all these video creators,
there's 80,000 of them.
I should be paying less.
- Right.
- I wouldn't blame the area,
I would blame the supply and demand.
Photography is a fucked
up supply and demand game.
- Yes.
- There are so many people
that love it so much,
like, you know, right now
somebody is listening like,
this motherfucker, he's
actually got a good job,
he's fucking me up because
photography is my life,
and him doing that on the
side is fucking me up.
You see where I'm going?
- But, for my business
I have not focused on,
I do head shots and stuff
like that for customers.
But I also targeted medical
supply build and photography.
- Good, I like that.
- So, what I've done
there is, I've literally
taken my skills, not
in the space of what's
in Connecticut but more
so going out of state,
and done jobs for a
company that contracts me
to contract other people.
- Okay.
- So while I can still be creative,
with my own photography,
for my business perspective,
I can subcontract another photographer,
which I am actually helping
other photographers.
- And real quick, let's
not demonize the state of
fucking Connecticut, let's demonize that
maybe for the industry
that you're focused on,
for example, if you were thinking about
CPG companies, food companies and
doing photos for brands and food,
you would fucking love Connecticut
because Westchester and
Connecticut are loaded.
- Yes.
- So, you see where I'm going?
- I got you.
- I'm glad you're picking it up.
- I didn't think about that,
and the irony behind that is,
jokingly, not jokingly, but Hennessy white
is a brand, and you can't
really buy it in the states
but I've done some product
photography on my own,
just kind of playing around
with my own camera gear,
posted it, and I was like
I could really do this
as a business, I could do
that as something else.
I never thought about
it as, okay why not do
more product photography
stuff, then really more,
I can still be creative,
and I can still get my,
Okay, I got it.
Good point, good point, good point.
- You demonized the
serendipity of which businesses
are in the state or the
general area you're in,
instead of realizing, wait a minute,
I can reverse this, and deploy creativity,
which is that's the scratch
you're trying to get at.
That itch.
There's part of,
if you were doing horse photography,
there's parts of Connecticut
where you could roll it up.
- Oh yeah, oh yeah, I
know of a few places.
- You understand?
- I got you, I got you.
So just change the mindset
of what I'm looking at
and not more so, okay got you.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
That's what I love about this show,
thank you my man.
That's what I love about
this show, like man,
Dustin do you understand the Yoda shit?
- [Dustin] Definitely.
- Like it's real man.
The answers are out there, you know
natural talent and
experience to me in this
great place of like, I just see it.
- [Dustin] Yeah.
- I fucking see it.
- [Dustin] Just need someone
to kind of clarify it
for us sometimes.
- Yeah, because I just see it.
Like I understand it.
Like, I can help and I want to help.
When you can see it, and you want to help,
it's fucking game over.
Let's keep this going.
Give me on sec here.
You can get it kind of going.
Uh-oh, somebody just
signed up for winetext.com
There we go Lana, you get a follow.
Thank you so much, wait until you see
today's cabernet offer.
If you love cabernet, today is,
if you're a silver oak, caymus, cakebread,
today's cabernet offer is out of control.
Matt, what's good?
- What's up Gary?
I tried, I've been taking your tips.
I did a post the other day
that I thought was horrible,
and it actually did good.
- Yes!
- It was actually the part of it!
- Wait, one more time for everybody,
Matt, one more time for
everybody's listening.
- So I play, I'm a
musician, I play guitar,
I love songwriting,
that's my favorite thing,
I did this bit on the guitar
and I screwed up a little bit,
I'm like, I'm not going to post this,
and then I was like, you know what?
You know what?
Start documenting, stop you know.
So I posted it, it's the best post.
It's got the most likes I've ever had.
- Makes me so fucking happy.
- Matt, this is happening
5,000 times a day,
to 5,000,000 times a day,
50 billion times a day,
people are overthinking this shit.
Thank you so much for sharing that story,
you just helped 54 people watching this.
- Yeah, because yourself can't judge
what the market is going to think.
- I have nothing but humility,
I never think I'm right.
I'm just curious what the
market is going to say,
and that's why I make.
This isn't about being right
or being a perfectionist,
or thinking I'm right, this
is about me being curious
what the market is going to say.
I enjoy the feedback loop from the content
more than the content.
- Yeah.
- Because it's for them, it's not for me.
Everyone is selfish and insecure.
I'm selfless and curious.
And confident as fuck.
- That's why I was going to ask you,
I started doing some posts on,
like I love writing songs,
that's what I love to do.
I started doing some posts on tutorials,
the software that I use, those do good.
As an original songwriter, it's hard.
Like people don't,
unless I have a hit song,
I don't know if people care, you know?
- Matt, something I've
been thinking a lot about,
something I've been thinking
a ton about for songwriters,
how many songs, how much volume
of song writing can you do?
Give me like a, I can write
three songs in a week.
Or usually once a month.
Just you, your range.
Your general range.
I'm sure it ebbs and flows.
- I do like one piece a
month, but this is the thing,
I'm scared to release the shit,
I mean I have two albums out.
- I cannot believe you just said.
This is what I'm most
excited about, you ready?
I have a big idea.
- Yeah.
- I've been wanting to
share this, you're the man.
You ready?
- Yeah.
- I think that many
songwriters should literally
write songs and literally
post them for free
on their Instagram account,
and call it a day, and let
people fucking take it,
and actually make the song.
- How do you mean take it?
- Ready?
No, no, I mean I want you to write a song,
and literally post it on TikTok,
YouTube, Facebook, Instagram,
like the written fucking song.
Maybe you read it, and then you say,
and now you all take it.
- Oh!
- I believe that if you did that.
Eventually, some incredible artist
comes along makes the song,
it explodes,
you get nothing for it,
you're not getting the
residuals, the royalties,
but it changes the course of your career.
And that's better than this
shit sitting in your head,
or sitting in your fucking closet.
- I like that.
- It's a different twist, it's a big idea.
It's a big idea.
You know, I can see
somebody stumbling on it,
and then fucking hiring you to write.
Like Drake, like fucking Dixie chicks.
Like I just think it's fucking real bro.
I think it's real bro.
What's it doing in your
fucking head and on your pad?
Nothing.
- Yeah.
That's what I was going to ask you.
- A lot more songwriters
should put out there songs
for free on the internet and
not be sad when one of them
hits and gets no royalty.
And maybe the artist,
by the way, you may get lucky,
get a crazy up and coming
talented to do the song, it crushes,
and they are also a sweet soul,
and actually do pay you royalties, as if,
or set you a check, or if they didn't,
it would still give you the
exposure that leads to fucking
Carrie Underwood hitting
you up the next week.
- Yeah, yeah, exposure, yeah.
- Dude it's a lot better
than it's sitting on your pad
or in your head.
It's doing dick shit for you there.
It's doing jack shit for
you on your fucking pad.
- I know.
- And in your fucking head.
- It's nothing.
- Nothing, garbage, zero, doesn't exist.
- Sometimes I feel my biggest ambition,
the songwriting, is my biggest fear.
- Do you mean scared of your own dream?
- Yeah, but it's kind of enticing too.
Because it's so hard
and it's so challenging
that I want to do it.
Is that like you with the Jets?
- To me, the Jets thing
is kind of just like
something that's been around as a kid,
it's the process.
For me, if I was you,
I'd be doing what I just told you to do,
because I just love songwriting
and I want my songs to be heard,
and the idea of me
putting out on Instagram
the written lyrics and fucking,
whether it's Russ, well
he does his own shit,
but like Rihanna or
fucking an up and comer,
think about this, Billie
Eilish could have saw it
three years ago, sang it,
like I don't think people get it.
Like creativity sitting
in your own fucking head,
and in your fucking drawer,
ain't doing shit for you.
Then people get into like,
Oh I don't want to be taken advantage of.
I'm like, you can't be taken advantage of
when nobody gives a fuck about you.
So how do you become giving a fuck about,
you put it out for free.
That's what I believe in.
- Yeah.
- Matt, do you know how many agencies,
how many marketing agencies
and independent solo
marketing social media experts literally
spend their life consuming
all of my content for free,
and then selling it to somebody else?
And Vayner Media doesn't get it?
To the tunes of hundreds of millions.
- Yeah.
- I eat my own dog food.
(laughing)
- Do me a favor, do this for me.
Let this moment happen.
Post for free on TikTok,
and the way you do it on TikTok is maybe
the video is just a fucking
melody over the paper
you wrote it on, I don't
know how you write,
but and then like, in the copy
you literally write the song.
On Instagram maybe it's on,
how do you write?
Do you write on computer,
do you write on pad?
- I write with guitar
and then I record it.
I usually record it.
- And is this the music
and not the lyrics?
- Both music and lyrics.
- I love it bro.
Put it out for free,
put it out for free,
maybe you end it with,
hey, now you go record,
and feel, you literally play it,
and then every time, you're
like this was Matt W,
and now you the more
talented performer than me,
go take this for free,
and make your own version.
I'm telling you right now,
it will change your life as a writer.
I'm convinced.
- Okay.
Thanks Gary.
- You're welcome.
- Thanks buddy.
- We're innovating our here man.
God that just helped literally
somebody just watched that,
and changed the course
of their writing career.
I literally believe there's a 16 year old,
15 year old Tiffany in Milwaukee,
laying right now watching this.
This is why I love how life action works.
This show would have never happened
if not corona, she would
never be home to watch this
if it was not for corona,
she just heard that,
literally Tiffany in
Milwaukee, 15 year old,
who's writing in her journal,
who can't perform or
too scared to perform,
who would have never been discovered,
who's going to listen to me,
who's going to use that as motivation,
who's going to put it out,
and fucking her life is going to change.
And she's going to be one of
the great music writers of all time.
I really believe that.
And I can't wait to meet her
at the Grammy's in 21 years.
She comes up and gives me a huge hug,
and I'll just be like what?
And she's like Tea with Gary Vee, 2020.
Diane.
- Hey, hi Gary.
- Hey, how are you?
- I am like unbelievably stoked.
So, first of all, I want to say thank you.
I just found you like three months ago.
- Thank you.
- And I started watching like,
well here's the real story.
One night I was up, really crying,
and upset about stuff,
and knowing that I had to
face losing my job, the
company shutting down.
Just things, and I'm not
happy with it anyways.
Social services, project
coordinator, boring.
(laughing)
Anyway, a survival job.
I was up in the middle of the night,
2:30 in the morning, flashing through.
I'm going to do Facebook Ads,
I'm going to do this.
I don't know a thing about anything.
And I come across Gary Vee.
And it's the talk where you're in Jersey,
and you're going, "This
is some real shit man,"
"this is some real shit."
I start crying because I'm in Oregon now,
but I grew up in Jersey.
I was born in Paterson,
grew up in Garden county,
and I'm like, I sit right up in my bed,
I'm like yeah, oh my God, this is my guy.
And it was no click funnels,
you didn't want nothing from me,
you didn't want me to pray a prayer,
you didn't want me to do nothing.
And I'm like, Oh my God, I love this guy.
So, I've been so totally addicted to you,
people hate me now, I'm
like Gary this, Gary that.
I'm like Gary freaking Vee cheerleader.
My daughter makes fun of me.
She say's I have a crush on you.
I said he's too young, I'm not a cougar.
(laughing)
I'm like a Gary maniac.
But it's only because I'm
just feeding from the well.
I take notes, I just listen.
I take it all in.
And so I did this, I need
self-awareness thing.
And I figured out all these
years sitting in a job I hate,
I really love to write,
I went back into writing a little bit.
And because of you, because of you Gary,
I got myself a writing
coach, and last week,
oh my God, I pulled the freaking trigger,
and I put an article up on LinkedIn.
- I am so proud of you.
- I was shaking all damn day.
Oh my God, the world is
going to freaking blow up,
I listened to Gary.
(laughing)
I'm not kidding.
I've been to toast masters,
I've done some public speaking.
I mean, but I usually I dip my feet in,
and I back out again.
But people tell me that,
you should do this more.
And I kind of hide behind,
I got to pay the bills.
So, I better do my nine to five.
Well guess what, February
14th, my last day.
So like I'm overdosing on your stuff now.
(laughing)
- Thank you Diane.
Thank you.
- Anyway, I just love you.
- I love you back.
- The question is, I'm older,
do I have to tell?
- Not as old as you think.
You don't have to tell me,
but I'm more than happy to hear it.
- Good.
- Whatever fucking number you say,
you know I'm going to say you're young,
because it's true.
- I know, I know.
So, my question is, I
really have to change gears.
I want to change gears.
I feel like I've been sitting on this fire
like a volcano all these years.
And I just feel like
now is the right time.
- That makes me so happy.
- And when you see this COVID,
I would have been at work,
I wouldn't have been listening to you.
Well maybe I would've been
watching quietly on my desk.
My boss not knowing.
(laughing)
(hushing)
Yeah, she's gone now.
(laughing)
I just don't know where to go now.
- What do you want to do?
- Well, I write and I'm writing actually
on the fifth chapter of the story of me.
And I did that because you
did this self-awareness talk,
and I'm like, I need to tell this story.
So there's a lot of pain,
there's a lot of tragedy,
there's a lot of bullshit.
- Are you able to tell the truth,
are you really going there?
- Yeah, my article on
LinkedIn was very exposing,
and that other thing about you said about,
okay, if that's what is in your way,
just do what's in your way.
So, all right, I'm just going
to vomit the whole shit out.
Get it out there.
- Diane, do you have a Facebook?
- I do.
- Have you ever gone on Facebook live?
- No.
- Do you feel like when
you put out the LinkedIn,
did you get some comments?
- Oh yeah, I got a lot of feedback,
but a lot of people didn't
put it in the channel,
they put it private DM me,
and I was like, put it out there!
And they were like, they
don't want to do it.
- That's okay, I get that.
Because they are sharing with you certain
things they don't want
other people to see.
- Diane, I'm sure right now on Twitter,
and of the Facebook live,
and on the LinkedIn live,
people are like, oh my
God, I love this woman.
You have such an authentic kind of,
it's so funny, I would have,
if you didn't say it
earlier at this point,
I would have asked you are
you from Brooklyn or New York.
You got that East Coast gal thing.
I think that you could potentially
be very interesting on live.
Where you just talk and answer,
I think you should do what I do.
Listen, you know what I'm great at?
I'm great at being Gary Vaynerchuk.
And staying in my lane, and
talking about what I know,
and not talking about what I don't know.
You don't hear me talking
about a ton of shit.
Because I just don't know.
And I have a funny intuitive feeling that
you could just be really
great at being Diana Melville,
and I really think that you should try.
- Wow.
Yeah.
- I think that you should
go on Facebook live,
see who shows up, you
obviously got friends,
relatives, co-workers,
former high school friends.
And just talk.
- About anything?
My book, anything?
I could talk about you all day.
- Well I appreciate
that, I think you should
talk about, I like stories a lot.
Let's play a little bit.
- Okay.
- Tell me a funny story, happy,
sad and different, tell me a story,
what high school did you go to in Jersey?
Allentown.
- Allentown PA?
- No, no, Allentown, New
Jersey, it's central.
- Oh I know where that,
wait a minute, Allentown,
give me the other, wait a minute.
Allentown?
- Exit 7A.
(laughing)
- On what, on the turnpike?
- Yeah.
- Got it, by Jackson?
Where Great Adventure is?
- Yes, yes, yes real
close to Great Adventure.
- Great, so give me a
story from high school.
Anything, go.
Freshman year, senior year.
- I wanted to be a cheerleader,
and I wasn't real coordinated,
but I was kind of like trying to
be in with the popular kids.
So I went, I can't believe
I'm telling this story.
- I love you.
I can, because I think
you are a natural talent.
I think you are a natural
fucking talent at this, Diane.
You're already entertaining
me and everybody else.
I'm telling you that right, keep going.
(laughing)
- That's awesome.
So, I get ready, I'm trying
to do the clap and the thing,
and it was a basketball cheerleader,
they needed for basketball squad.
And, I get all like, my
friends are cheering.
I get up there, and I screw it up.
I mean I'm out of sync,
I'm total white girl.
Got no rhythm, I can't bop, I can't do it.
Okay, so they all love me so much,
they gave me a golden freaking megaphone,
and made me honorary cheerleader.
Kind of like a mascot.
- Because they liked you so
much, but you sucked shit at it.
- Yeah, they just kind of like owned me.
You know?
I was like, I'm in!
I didn't give a shit.
- You know what though,
that little micro story,
in itself, as you develop your
game of talking with people
and things of that
nature, has so much to it.
Because that then becomes a lesson.
It becomes a lesson of courage,
and not worrying about it.
It becomes a lesson of like
insecurity slash wanting to fit in,
gave you the energy to do that.
It was a lesson of
compassion and kindness from
the people that took you in,
even though you couldn't do it.
There's just a lot there Diane.
- Yeah.
- Who was the cutest boy in high school?
- Oh, he's still mad at
me, his name is Pete.
(laughing)
I chased him, what can I say?
- Listen, you've got conviction.
I appreciate it.
Diane, listen to me.
Story time.
Stories, lessons, a lot of stories around
don't be like me, I did
a job just for safety.
I was scared.
I was taught, I don't
know if this is true,
I'm just making some stuff up now.
I was taught by my parents to
just get a safe stable job,
don't be like me, I regret it.
But it's not over yet for me.
So for all of you it's not over.
Don't take that bullshit job.
Follow your dreams.
I had the courage to
finally write something.
- Right.
- Like, Diane, you're entertaining.
You've even got your sayings of like,
I didn't have it,
like you've got a little shtick.
The reason people told
you to do more of it is,
you have it in you.
I can see it from a mile away.
- Oh my God, I love you Gary.
(kissing)
- I love you more.
Listen to me Diane.
- You're like my brother.
- Listen to me, listen
to me, you have to do
LinkedIn and Facebook lives.
Try it.
- Okay, I will.
- [Dustin] I would also
say do TikToks too,
I see a lot people doing
that type of stuff there.
- Yeah, TikTok.
- Yeah, good job Dustin.
Yeah, listen, Diane, make.
Keep going down this Gary Vee train,
and you won't need it.
And you will live a happy fucking life.
I see it in you, you've got this.
(clapping)
- Yay!
All right Gary!
- Great, good luck, take care.
- Bye.
- I'm going to end it with that everybody.
I hope you enjoyed
today's Tea with Gary Vee,
I thought it was the
best episode to be frank.
I think the cadence is getting there.
I think we got through a lot of questions.
I think there was a
lot of fucking lessons.
I hope one really hit you in your soul,
and now the most important
part of Tea with Gary Vee,
which is the do part.
Right now, you're inspired.
Right now, you see the observation.
The question now is,
will you take the energy.
And I think the 11 AM to noon hour
of the Tea with Gary Vee show,
is the most important part.
Now, take this energy.
Now, take this momentum.
Now, go fucking do.
Don't dwell, do.
Don't complain, create.
You know?
Don't mope, make.
Like fucking this is your opportunity.
Please use this incredibly
difficult global pandemic
tragedy for so many unfortunately.
Tragedy for so many.
Be grateful that you
aren't losing a loved one.
Or you yourself are not losing your life,
and go take advantage of it.
Please go.
I believe in you.
I believe in you a lot more
than you believe in yourself.
I believe in the internet.
I believe in these platforms.
I believe in the opportunity.
I believe in it.
Please.
Please use my energy to
give you the courage.
Please use my energy
to be your confidence.
Please use my energy to
cut out the insecurity,
and the bad parenting or bad
environment, or insecurity.
Or bad situation.
This is our fucking shot.
Please, I love you.
Dustin thank you for being
on the one's and two's.
I'll see everybody
tomorrow, nine am eastern.
Please share this.
Take a screenshot now.
Please get your friends.
Get a text group, get a whatsapp group,
post this on your Facebook group.
Let's get people watching this show.
It's fucking doing good.
I can feel it in my fucking bones.
(upbeat music)